Un domaine où l'informatique quantique pourrait améliorer l'apprentissage automatique
est lié aux fonctions noyau ou
matrices noyau — voyons ce que c'est
et pourquoi on en a besoin. Pour ça, on va se rappeler
trois choses : pourquoi le produit scalaire apparaît-il en apprentissage automatique,
pourquoi les problèmes d'apprentissage automatique impliquent-ils des dimensions élevées,
et qu'est-ce que les fonctions noyau ?
Rappelle-toi que le produit scalaire, ou produit intérieur,
de vecteurs réels à n dimensions a
et b est donné par le produit de la magnitude de a,
de la magnitude de b et du cosinus de thêta, l'angle
entre eux. C'est équivalent à multiplier
chaque composante de a par la composante correspondante de
b, puis de sommer. Note que si les vecteurs sont
presque orthogonaux, comme quand a
a des composantes nulles là où b en a de grandes,
le produit scalaire est petit. C'est équivalent à
thêta qui s'approche de pi sur deux.
De même, si a a des composantes négatives là où b
a des composantes positives,
ce qui veut dire que les vecteurs pointent dans
des directions presque opposées
et que thêta est proche de pi,
le résultat du produit scalaire peut être
négatif. Enfin, si a a de grandes composantes là où b
a aussi de grandes composantes du même signe,
donc que les vecteurs sont presque parallèles et que thêta est proche de zéro,
le produit scalaire sera grand
et positif. Il est donc tout à fait raisonnable de s'attendre à ce que les produits scalaires
soient une mesure utile de similarité
entre points de données. Toutes les données à n dimensions
ne peuvent pas être facilement séparées par une coupe en n moins
une dimension, c'est-à-dire une ligne,
un plan ou un hyperplan. Quand les données ne sont pas bien séparées
en n dimensions, on peut plonger les points de données
dans des dimensions supérieures, disons m dimensions, où m
est supérieur à n. C'est ce qu'on appelle un plongement de caractéristiques,
souvent noté x allant vers phi(x), où
phi(x) est une application des réels à n dimensions vers
les réels à m dimensions.
C'est plus facile à visualiser en
repliant des données à une dimension dans
deux dimensions, ou en prenant des données à deux dimensions
et en les plongeant dans trois dimensions.
Mais en pratique, on plonge souvent les données dans des espaces à des milliers,
voire des millions de dimensions.
Un produit scalaire de vecteurs à trois dimensions comparé à un produit scalaire
de vecteurs à deux dimensions représente une différence négligeable.
Mais un produit scalaire de vecteurs à un million de dimensions
devient totalement intraitable
à appliquer à un grand jeu de données.
Alors les gens ont eu une astuce ingénieuse :
et si on utilisait une projection
vers des dimensions supérieures d'une forme très spécifique,
telle que les produits scalaires des vecteurs dans
les dimensions supérieures sont une fonction simple des
vecteurs en dimension inférieure ? Autrement dit, on cherche une application
de nos données x vers phi(x) en dimension supérieure,
telle que le produit intérieur dans
l'espace des caractéristiques soit donné par une
fonction simple des données en dimension inférieure.
Cette fonction k s'appelle une fonction noyau.
Idéalement, on voudrait que cette fonction noyau
soit une fonction du produit intérieur
en dimension inférieure lui-même, ce qui nous donnerait le
meilleur des deux mondes : un espace de caractéristiques de très haute dimension
mais avec un produit intérieur simple et rapide à calculer.
À première vue, il n'est pas
évident que ce soit même possible. Regardons
un exemple simple en très basse dimension.
Considère ce plongement de caractéristiques spécifique : il prend un
vecteur à trois dimensions et le plonge dans un
espace à neuf dimensions. Il se trouve
que le produit intérieur dans l'espace de caractéristiques à neuf dimensions
est simplement donné par le produit intérieur dans l'espace
3D original, au carré. Donc le produit intérieur
dans l'espace transformé avec les fonctions phi
nécessiterait de calculer chacune des
neuf coordonnées pour le
premier vecteur, et neuf pour le
deuxième, puis le produit intérieur lui-même, ce qui représente
encore neuf produits et une somme :
soit vingt-huit opérations au total.
La fonction noyau ne nécessite que trois produits
et deux sommes, ce qui correspond à seulement quatre opérations.
C'était pour le cas d'un point de données à trois dimensions plongé dans
un espace de caractéristiques à neuf dimensions.
On voit facilement à quel point ça peut être très avantageux
pour des espaces très grands.
La fonction noyau est typiquement une fonction continue
que tu peux appliquer à n'importe quel vecteur de ton jeu de données.
Mais on utilise les fonctions noyau en prenant
des paires de points de données de notre ensemble
comme arguments. Appliquer une fonction noyau à
chaque paire de points de données de l'ensemble
donne une matrice symétrique appelée la matrice
noyau. Le type de fonction noyau à utiliser dépend de
ton problème. Donc pour récapituler :
décrire la similarité des vecteurs dans nos jeux de données
nécessite souvent des produits intérieurs. Les produits intérieurs dans
des espaces de caractéristiques de très haute dimension deviennent coûteux,
donc on utilise des plongements de caractéristiques correspondant
à certaines fonctions noyau spéciales
qui rendent le calcul plus efficace.
Mais cette restriction aux fonctions noyau spéciales
limite les types de plongements dans l'espace de caractéristiques qui peuvent
être réalisés efficacement. Ça
peut nous empêcher de bien séparer nos données.
Si seulement il y avait une autre façon de faire…
C'est là qu'intervient l'informatique quantique.
Le plongement de caractéristiques de très haute dimension correspondant
aux fonctions noyau peut être réalisé
sur un ordinateur quantique grâce au quantum kernel estimator.
La matrice noyau k est calculée,
et à partir de là, un algorithme d'apprentissage automatique classique peut être
utilisé. Pour ça, un point de données x1
est chargé et transformé, puis
un autre x2 est chargé
et transformé. Puisque le produit intérieur de deux états quantiques
est lié à la probabilité de mesure,
on peut estimer le produit intérieur des deux points de données transformés
en effectuant suffisamment de mesures du
circuit résultant. De cette façon, notre circuit
peut nous renseigner sur un produit intérieur
dans n'importe quel espace de haute dimension que le circuit peut modéliser,
sans jamais calculer classiquement un produit intérieur ou une
fonction noyau. Il existe de nombreuses façons de
personnaliser et d'améliorer ces méthodes,
et de nouvelles méthodes sont constamment proposées
et testées. On espère que cet
aperçu t'a été utile pour comprendre comment
l'informatique quantique s'applique
aux méthodes d'apprentissage automatique,
en particulier celles qui impliquent les noyaux.